[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
allora al centro della mia vita
artistica lo avete visto cioè il muro ma
che cosa in più un muro rispetto a una
tela un foglio di carta una volta
dipingendo a napoli in un vicolo che si
avvicinano la signora mi dice bello ma
perchè non fai su tela un'altra volta
camminavo a madrid
vedo muro che mi piace per via delle
paghe il tempo che è passato così a
pieno giorno deciso di entrare dentro
dico al signore e proprietario posso
dipingere il suo muro mi guarda mi dice
graffiti si guarda il nelle mie opere e
le piacciono e così mi domanda ma vuoi
essere pagata non lo faccio perché il
muro mi piace quindi mi ha dato l'idea
per un disegno che ha in testa non mi
guarda che lascia fare e poi dice allora
me lo faresti anche dentro ma dentro no
ok così che cosa in più un muro rispetto
ma tela
una storia questa è la mia storia
io mi chiamo alice pasquini però molti
mi conoscono semplicemente come alice ho
deciso di firmare col mio vero nome
in un mondo quello dei graffiti
prevalentemente maschile è fatto
soprattutto di alias come tag dipingere
col mio vero nome è stato un modo per
portare anche una visione più femminile
sui muri e dove spesso la donna ne
arriva rappresentata in un certo modo
come eroina dei fumetti oppure bomba
sexy per me dipingere sul muro voleva
andare anche dire andare oltre i limiti
della terra o una formazione accademica
in arte ed è proprio per questo che sono
andato a registrata probabilmente da
piccola pensavo che fare l'artista fosse
un lavoro come un altro infatti nel mio
mondo c'era il puffo
infermiere il buffo poliziotto il cuoco
e anche il pittore così come nel mondo
del primo bill per esempio
così quando sono arrivato a risorti
stick ora negli anni 90 e diciamo la
cultura hip hop arrivava prepotentemente
in italia la mattina
disegnavo la modella il pomeriggio
imparavo altro all'accademia di belle
arti il mio professore nel corso di
pittura entrare in aula dicendo l'arte è
morta conducente lasciate perdere il
disegno tanto finire tutti senza lavoro
così nello spirito ma questa cosa
diciamo che io ho cominciato per
reazione uscire nelle strade la cosa
immediata è stata a prendere un mio
disegno e attaccarlo sul muro ma poi ci
sono state frigoriferi abbandonati
cabine telefoniche dismesse un chiosco
della birra e possibili in poi la strada
la strada in tanti luoghi per esempio a
melilla nel carcere femminile
nell'enclave spagnola in marocco dove ho
dipinto una donna su un albero che
guarda il futuro guardate il durante
l'ora d'aria che era il tempo in cui
avevo per realizzare quel murales e dove
mi avevano detto che ciò che le mancava
di più era la natura è l'orizzonte
ho lavorato anche con i ragazzi
immigrati qui in italia a roma anziano
allora ho nessuno parlava alla stessa
lingua
abbiamo progettato un muro pensando alle
cose che volano una città che vola
ideale attraverso i disegni mi hanno
raccontato le loro esperienze loro
traumi di guerra ed era per alcuni la
prima volta proprio che dipingevano
sicuramente il primo muro della loro
vita o anche raccontato le storie degli
emigrati all'estero italiani che
facevano questi lunghissimi viaggi
ammassati nelle barche per giorni e
giorni prima ad arrivare alla terra
promessa
ecco per me
questo è il muro in più di una pena una
storia ma anche un modo simbolo per
andare oltre certe cose
quando ho finito l'accademia di belle
arti
ho trovato anche un lavoro ben pagato
però non ero contenta sapevo che non si
poteva fare l'artista 50 per cento così
mi sono dato un anno di tempo e ha detto
vediamo quello che succede
sono andata prima madrid poi a parigi
avevo un sacco di tempo libero veramente
ovunque ho viaggiato in tutto il mondo è
stato per me anche un modo di raccontare
le storie tutte quelle storie che
nascono in primo luogo sui miei quaderni
quaderni che porto sempre con me come un
diario di viaggio una raccolta di
emozioni e di sentimenti ma anche di
soggetti e luoghi che poi troveranno
posto su un piccolo angolo di strada o
su una parete enorme quando ho dipinto
in strada e così avevo moltissimo tempo
libero sono state spesso le persone a
dirmi a darmi dei lavori a propormi
anche lo so tatuaggi e disegnato nipoti
cani ma donne anche queste cose però
sono state sempre le persone a
sopportarmi tutti questi viaggi da un
luogo all'altro credo che lasciare una
storia sul muro sia la cosa più
importante ma anche quando uno va via io
disegno il numero in fondo non lo vivono
me ne vado però chi ci abita davanti
ogni giorno lo vedrà quindi una volta
ero a new york stavo dipingendo un muro
che è in realtà erano tre in tre diverse
città e portavano la storia del rock and
beach dove c'era stata dura gago sandy
fino a new york
e mentre dipingeva secondo muro in new
jersey
stavo giocando con il testo punto nome
della città new jersey componendo una
scritta che era i sogni sono l'inizio di
un nuovo viaggio quindi news
che new jersey mentre stava dipingendo
una signora era veramente arrabbiata è
venuto verso di me ne ha detto nessuno
mi ha detto che avresti di vento questo
muro e così il giorno dopo non mi
aspettavo quello che mi è venuta a dire
con le lacrime agli occhi si avvicina
tami ha detto scusami per gli aerei e
sto attraversando un momento molto duro
della mia vita a mio figlio dei problemi
di autismo però arrivando al lavoro
questa mattina ho pensato che quella
scritta era un messaggio per me m'ha
detto vedi quella sono io che indica a
mio figlio un areoplanino in aria e dice
vedi cesta futuro così in fondo il muro
e di chi lo vive di chi poi lo vede ma
lo stesso tempo appunto mentre ero a new
york
ricevo ad esempio una mail da un
piccolissimo borgo del molise dove mi
chiedono se fosse interessata al mare a
dipingere lì a civitacampomarano la
popolazione quasi un paese disabitato
ormai ci sono pochissime persone per lo
più anziani e bambini sono quattro sono
figli degli immigrati
quello che l'autrice delle mail non
sapeva era che per me non era un paese
qualsiasi bensì il paese dove è nato mio
nonno così ho deciso volta tornato
dall'america di andare a dipingere lì su
quei palazzi e su quelle porte ormai
consumate dal tempo e raccontare la vita
del paese che ormai non c'è più
chiaramente tutti gli abitanti mi
dicevano ma perché non dipinge il muro
bianco intonacato no nostante neanche
comunque la fine l'ho fatto
la cosa interessante che hanno
cominciato andarci turisti è uscito un
servizio del giornale delle 8 qualche
articolo del giornale e sono tornati i
turisti anche stranieri a civita così
non ci potevano credere
e allora l'anno dopo ho deciso di
tornare insieme ad alcuni amici e fare
un progetto un progetto specifico per me
oggi la chiamano street art
io preferisco arte contestuale voglio
dire che nasce per un luogo e non per un
altro che nasce per quel muro perché a
quella storia quel colore i colori
intorno
e non può essere la stessa cosa da
sydney a mosca per me questa esperienza
in cui sono riuscito a ridare vita al
paese per una settimana riportando anche
bambini che non c'erano più
è stata un'esperienza di vita che mi fa
pensare che appunto oltre al muro
comunque si possono creare dei legami e
spesso il muro in fondo è un simbolo
molto forte dunque nel frattempo mentre
io punto cercavo lavoro per le strade di
parigi e dipingevo è successo che la
street art
ha cominciato avere un grande successo e
quindi sono andati festival e curatori
arte mostre e musei chi se lo sarebbe
aspettato quando ero piccola se mi
avessero detto che un giorno fare
graffiti sarebbe stato il mio lavoro mi
sarei messo a ridere però nel frattempo
io ero interessata esprimere una parte
più femminile appunto in questo contesto
perché non non c'era una
rappresentazione della donna come donna
vera che come con un suo particolare
carattere una personalità quando tutto
sembrava andare molto bene lo stesso
anno in cui uscivo come artista sono
importante enciclopedia venivo
intervistata da uno dei principali
quotidiani americani mi arrivava anche
una denuncia per imbrattamento e devo
dire che insomma è stato un paradosso un
po duro da accettare però ancora una
volta sono state le persone che mi hanno
scritto e sono state vicine anche
sconosciuti dall'inizio devo dire tutto
questo percorso no quando per me in
fondo era solo un gioco sempre sono
state le persone a supportarmi e a
spingermi ad andare avanti e divertente
pensare che l'anno il cui che io ho
fatto l'esame di quinta elementare
il mio tema era sulla caduta del muro di
berlino
devo dire che da allora ad oggi i muri
purtroppo come dicevamo sono solo
aumentate
ecco allora ancora una volta che cosa
vuol dire perché un muro per me
dipingere su un muro vuol dire in
qualche modo anche attraversato
no
[Musica]